.
I THINK THAT, FIRST, IT WAS A
CAMPAIGN PROMISE WHICH ACTUALLY
GOT THE HIGHEST AMOUNT OF VOTERS
EVER TO TURN OUT.
STUDENT LOAN DEBT WAS A TOPIC
THAT PEOPLE ACTUALLY WENT TO THE
POLLS FOR.
AND I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO GO
TO THE POLLS THIS CYCLE.
I'M RIDDLED WITH STUDENT LOAN
DEBT.
I'M FROM THE CONGRESSMAN'S HOME
STATE OF OHIO.
AND YOUR HOME STATE, AN EIGHTH
OF YOUR POPULATION COULD
ACTUALLY BENEFIT FROM THIS
PROGRAM.
AND I THINK PEOPLE SHOULD BE
REALLY CAREFUL ABOUT MAKING FUN
OF FOLKS WHO HAVE STUDENT LOAN
DEBT.
THERE ARE TEACHERS, THERE ARE
NURSES, THERE ARE FIREFIGHTERS,
THERE ARE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE PUBLIC
SERVANTS THAT HAVE DARE THEY'RE
NOT GETTING A MINIMUM WAGE RAISE
BECAUSE WE KNOW THE REPUBLICANS
DON'T WANT TO DO THAT.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT PRE-K.
PEOPLE AREN'T PASSING POLICIES
TO HELP OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM.
THEY ARE PEOPLE WHO CAN'T GET
FROM UNDER IT BECAUSE THE WAY
THE INTEREST IS SET UP.
IT IS A DIFFERENT TYPE OF LOAN
BECAUSE WHEN YOU TAKE OUT A
HOUSE MORTGAGE, YOU CAN ACTUALLY
SELL THAT HOUSE AND GET RID OF
THAT DEBT.
YOU CAN'T GET RID OF STUDENT
LOAN DEBT.
IT IS WITH YOU FOR THE REST OF
YOUR LIFE.
>> THE PROBLEM WITH THIS IS THIS
DOES ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF HIGHER
EDUCATION BEING UNAFFORDABLE.
THE FACT WE'RE SAYING PEOPLE
MAKING SIX FIGURES, $125,000 A
YEAR, ARE GOING TO HAVE THEIR
STUDENT DEBT FORGIVEN WHEN THE
MEDIAN INCOME IN THIS COUNTRY IS
$67,000 A YEAR.
I AM ALL FOR MORE PROGRAMS IF WE
WANT TO HAVE LOAN FORGIVENESS
FOR TEACHERS, FOR NURSES,
AMERICORP, THOSE WORK.
A THIRD OF THIS COUNTRY DIDN'T
HAVE THE CREDIT TO TAKE OUT A
LOAN THEY CAN'T PLAY BACK.
IT PLAYS TO THE NOTION, I'M
SORRY, THE DEMOCRATS ARE
BECOMING A PARTY OF ELITES.
DONALD TRUMP PLAYED TO THAT.
THERE'S A REASON WORKING
AMERICANS TURNED OUT FOR DONALD
TRUMP, WHO I'M NO FAN OF, BUT
IT'S PLAYING INTO THAT.
>> IT'S A NEW FEELING, THIRD
PERSON AT THE TABLE JUMPING ONTO
A DOG PILE.
>> NEW ROLE FOR SCOTT JENNINGS.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
I THINK MANY IMPORTANT AND SMART
THINGS HAVE BEEN SAID AT THIS
TABLE.
I'LL ADD A COUPLE.
I FEEL LIKE WE'VE REACHED THE
JOKER PHASE OF THE BIDEN
PRESIDENTS.
HE'S RIDING A PARADE FLOAT DOWN
PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE TOSSING
MONEY OUT THE WINDOW.
IT'S TOTALLY LAWLESS, COMPLETELY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL, COMPLETELY IN
VIOLATION OF OUR NORM.
YOU GOT A PRESIDENT WITH NO
AGREEMENT FROM CONGRESS SPENDING
UP TO HALF A TRILLION DOLLARS.
THIS IS A MASSIVE, MASSIVE
THING.
AND IT'S UNPRECEDENTED.
AND BIDEN RAN AS SOMEONE WHO WAS
GOING TO RESTORE OUR NORMS AND
RESTORE THE BALANCE AND RESTORE
OUR, YOU KNOW, LAWS AND
INSTITUTIONS.
AND THIS IS COMPLETELY IN
OPPOSITION TO ALL OF THAT, ALL
FOR POLITICS.
SOME PEOPLE ANALYZE IT'S FOR
POLITICS OF THE MIDTERM.
THIS IS PRIMARY POLITICS.
THIS IS A GUY WHO WANTS TO RUN
FOR RE-ELECTION.
IN T